Donald Trump has published.
I can't say for sure that he's written it.
Maybe he did.
Maybe he just had it published.
I don't know.
But Donald Trump has published a letter about
the impeachment trial that starts today.
Now, recall that Donald Trump is the only
president in history to be impeached twice.
And his second trial starts today.
The first day of debate is actually going
to be about whether the impeachment trial
is constitutional.
If that gets 51 votes or 50 50 with Kamala
Harris as the tiebreaker saying that the trial
is constitutional, then the trial will sort
of start in earnest tomorrow.
So Donald Trump wrote a letter yesterday arguing
that the trial is not constitutional.
Donald Trump wrote from the office of Donald
Trump with a sort of presidential looking
SEAL statement on the next phase of the unconstitutional
impeachment trial.
President Donald Trump's legal team issued
the following statement regarding the next
phase of the unconstitutional impeachment
trial.
President Trump and his counsel are pleased
that there was bipartisan support on how to
structure the impeachment trial.
We appreciate that Senate Republican leadership
stood strong for due process and secured a
structure that is consistent with past precedent,
past precedent.
By the way, this process will provide us with
an opportunity to explain to senators why
it is absurd and unconstitutional to hold
an impeachment trial against a private citizen.
Now, hilariously, the letter has the presidential
seal at the top.
It says President Donald Trump's legal team.
It says President Trump.
And then it says it's all unconstitutional
because this is just a private citizen.
This is just some guy.
You can't do this.
I've never seen private citizens use the seal
in letterhead for private letters.
It's very interesting that Donald Trump is
doing that now.
I know he gets the title president for life,
but if you want to play up the unconstitutionality
of the trial based on Trump being a private
citizen, maybe play down the references to
President Trump, maybe don't have the presidential
seal taking up half the page.
And I can't believe I'm saying this, but if
a private citizen incited an insurrection,
that would also be a big deal.
And we're actually going to talk about the
criminal aspect a little bit later when we
look at some statements from Senator Rand
Paul about this.
But it's being overlooked that private citizens
also would have repercussions for inciting
insurrection.
So the Trump legal team and Trump together,
it's like the blind leading the blind.
They want to pretend he's still president,
but also say he can't be tried because he's
not the president anymore.
And the logic doesn't pass the sniff test.
If a CEO of a company is charged for embezzling
and then fired and at the time of the trial,
they've been fired.
Right.
They're no longer the CEO.
Could they say, well, I don't I don't work
there anymore.
You can't try me for embezzling, embezzlement.
I'm not there anymore.
This is the exact same thing that's going
on with Donald Trump.
He was, by the way, impeached while in office.
Trump was still not that it matters, but Trump
was impeached while in office.
So imagine being, I don't know, one of these
lawyers and having to deal with Donald Trump
right now.
And it probably explains this letter.
Seeing this letter explains much of why many
of Trump's lawyers quit last week.
And on the merits, it's completely constitutional.
Even if they had not impeach Trump until after
he was president, it would still be constitutional.
But Trump was president when he was impeached.
This is merely the trial.
So there is no good legal argument for why
the trial can't happen after Trump is out
of office.
Trump is a scam.
This is all a scam.
And from the point of view of Trump's unending
narcissism, he's also planning to have his
lawyers portray him as the victim during these
entire proceedings.
And I want to talk about
that next.